Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Bonjour à tous !
J’ai quatorze minutes à passer avec vous.
Je vais surtout essayer de vous faire
prendre conscience de votre regard.
Mais de quel regard je parle ?
Petit exercice : je vais vous
demander de fermer les yeux
et de vous imaginer avec quelques années
de plus, voire beaucoup, beaucoup plus.
Je vous demande effectivement
d’être des seniors, aînés,
ou vieux, vieux terme noble et beau.
Petit exercice terminé.
Je suppose que certains d’entre vous
ont pu voir des belles images
avec beaucoup de chaleur, de l’amour,
des couloirs chaleureux,
de la vie autour d’eux.
Mais peut-être d’autres
ont pu voir des couloirs blancs,
avec un isolement, de la solitude,
avec des manques de câlins.
Ces images tellement négatives
qui font peur,
qui nous font penser que
la vieillesse est une étape difficile.
Pourtant, je me dis tous les jours
que vieillir est une chance
et je l’impose surtout à mes habitants.
Parce que moi, j'ai la chance d'être maire
d'une commune de 72 habitants.
Moyenne d'âge 87 ans et demi.
Eh oui, ça existe !
Vous êtes en train de vous dire
que je suis certainement
en train de perdre la tête.
Non, pas du tout.
Cette commune est née il y a cinq ans.
Mais peut-être qu’il est temps
que je vous raconte mon histoire.
Il y a dix ans, j'ai eu la chance de
vivre quelque chose de formidable.
Mon projet :
devenir directrice
d’une maison de retraite.
Parce que ma passion,
ce sont les personnes âgées,
mais pas toutes les personnes âgées :
les dépendantes, les manque d’autonomie,
et celles dont vous pensez :
« Je ne veux surtout pas
devenir comme celle-là. »
Eh bien oui, j’ai osé le défi de prendre
un poste en maison de retraite.
Et pourtant,
c’est avec beaucoup d’émotion,
encore cet après-midi
que je vais vous en parler.
Parce qu’il y a dix ans, quand
je suis arrivée dans l’établissement,
Je n'étais pas bien.
J’ai vu un tas de choses
qui ne me plaisaient pas.
On aurait certainement pu
faire la une d’Élise Lucet.
Nous étions maltraitants,
institutionnellement,
mais aussi individuellement.
Et je crois qu’il est de mon devoir,
cet après-midi,
de partager au moins deux expériences.
Est-ce que vous vous êtes déjà imaginé,
lorsque quelqu’un arrive
vous faire la toilette ?
Non pas une personne, mais deux qui
arrivent dans votre chambre avec force,
l’essentiel étant de faire la toilette,
quelque chose de primordial
pour nous dans nos établissements.
On vous force à faire cette toilette,
notamment la petite toilette intime,
on vous demande d’écarter
les cuisses mais vous refusez.
Et là, ils se mettent à deux.
ils écartent les cuisses.
Est-ce qu’on ne pourrait pas parler là
de viol hygiénique ?
Ou encore lorsqu’à table,
on enlève cuillères et fourchettes
à la personne âgée pour aller plus vite
qu’elle va s’en mettre
plein sur son vêtement.
Ou alors elle va se salir de façon majeure
et on va lui donner la becquée
tout en regardant notre portable.
Parce que chose importante, ce portable.
Avons-nous le droit de faire ces actes ?
Quand est-ce qu’on nous a demandé
de faire de tels actes ?
Il y a dix ans, je me suis dit :
« Quel sens a encore notre pratique ?
Pourquoi faisons-nous tout ça ? »
Et je me suis dit :
« C’est maintenant ou jamais. »
Mon petit Jiminy Cricket m’a dit :
« Le changement peut être possible,
le regard peut changer. »
Je suis donc allée voir
mes équipes et j’ai dit :
« Stop ! On arrête de pratiquer comme ça.
Est-ce que vous êtes heureux ? »
Non, bien évidemment.
Donc, pendant deux ans,
2013 à 2015, j’ai pris soin d’eux.
On a appris à se regarder,
on a appris à se toucher,
on a appris à se dire les choses.
On a grandi ensemble.
J’ai fait des choses peut-être
pas tout à fait correctes.
C’est-à-dire : je leur ai fait vivre la
vie qu’ils faisaient vivre aux habitants.
Je leur ai donné la becquée,
je leur ai mis des protections,
je les ai mis dans des fauteuils.
Est-ce que j’avais le droit de le faire ?
Je n’en sais rien.
Mais aujourd’hui,
j’ai le fruit de mon travail.
Aujourd’hui, les soignants ont compris
le sens de leurs pratiques.
En 2015, je me suis dit : « Ça y est,
notre philosophie est née,
nous allons vivre un beau chemin de vie. »
Oh... trop facile !
Dans nos établissements,
nous avons quatre piliers.
Les soignants,
bien évidemment les habitants,
les familles et nos tutelles.
Après les habitants, les soignants,
je me suis orientée vers les familles.
Pas facile d'envoyer son parent dans
un établissement comme les nôtres.
Pas facile d'envoyer son conjoint.
Qu’est-ce qu’on vient chercher ?
La sécurité ? Mais quelle sécurité ?
On va aller vérifier si le linge
est bien rangé dans l’armoire,
s’il n’y a pas de moutons sous la table.
On va encore aller questionner
Papa et Maman pour dire :
« Qu’est-ce que tu as fait ?
Tu as bien mangé ?
Est-ce que tu as été en activité ? »
Est-ce que c’est ça le rôle des enfants,
lorsqu’on vient voir son parent
qui est pourtant démuni
et qui est dans une communauté ?
Est-ce que derrière la famille
ne doit pas se poser des questions
en se disant :
« Oui, je vais faire des câlins »,
« Oui, je vais retrouver maman,
oui je vais l'embrasser,
oui, je vais la sécuriser. »
Là encore, nous, institutions,
moi, maire ou directrice,
[avons] un rôle majeur
pour donner la sécurité aux familles,
pour les amener à prendre conscience
que leurs actes peuvent
être aussi maltraitants.
Dernier pilier de notre institution :
les tutelles.
Là, je vous avoue,
de toute façon, c’est déjà un échec.
Toutes les cases ne sont pas
cochées pour moi
et je pense que je n’y arriverai pas.
Donc à travers ces quatre piliers,
une nouvelle philosophie est née.
Est née la commune de Kersalic,
Kersalic où j’ai mes conseillers
municipaux, mes adjoints.
Mais j’ai surtout reconstitué avec toute
une équipe, une vraie commune,
avec notre brasserie ouverte
sept jours sur sept le midi.
Vous y êtes les bienvenus, vous devez
tout simplement être habillé chic.
Les charentaises sont acceptées.
Pourquoi une brasserie ?
Tout simplement parce que
nos habitants sont en vie
et qu’ils auraient envie effectivement
d’aller au petit resto du coin.
Mais également, nous avons -
j’essaye de nommer -
un bistrot ouvert à tout le monde,
un cinéma tous les dimanches soir,
une boutique deux fois par semaine,
tenue par des bénévoles.
Et une grande vie de collectivité,
mais vraiment de commune.
Est-ce que c’est possible ?
Vous êtes en train de vous dire :
« Oui, mais ça, c’est l’idéal.
Les habitants sont extraordinaires. »
Non. Attention, j’ai les mêmes
habitants que les autres.
Ils sont à 70, 75%
avec des troubles cognitifs.
Leur temporalité n'est pas la nôtre,
leur espace n'est pas le nôtre.
Pourquoi continuer à lutter, à vouloir
les amener dans notre monde à nous
alors qu’ils n’ont plus
les mêmes repères que nous ?
Nous avons donc créé un espace pour eux
avec des couloirs
qui ressemblent à des rues.
Nous avons une cheminée dans l'espace
commun pour être comme chez eux.
Nous avons 7 chats, 5 cochons d’Inde,
une poule qui circule dans les rues.
Et tout ça pour le vivre ensemble,
pour créer une communauté,
pour qu’on rentre dans leur monde à eux,
pour vivre avec eux
avec bienveillance et avec amour.
Aujourd'hui, on a arrêté nos pendules
pour faire tout ça.
On entend souvent :
« On n’a pas le temps. »
Chez nous, on a du temps parce que
l’habitant, il se lève quand il veut,
il mange quand il veut,
il se couche quand il veut,
il fait la fête quand il veut.
Ça veut dire que moi,
quand j’arrive le matin au travail,
je ne sais pas par quoi je commence.
Et ça, pour l’ensemble des soignants.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que l'essentiel, c'est de leur
faire partager notre quotidien.
Qu’elles aient encore une utilité,
ces personnes âgées,
qu’elles soient dans le donnant donnant.
J’ai peut-être perdu la notion du temps,
mais je sais encore éplucher les carottes.
Je ne sais peut-être plus dire
comment tu t’appelles,
mais je peux te prendre dans mes bras
et je peux t’embrasser.
Et c’est ça, l’essentiel de la vie.
Aujourd’hui, nos habitants,
ils travaillent, ils passent le balai,
ils font la soupe pour le soir.
Ils vivent avec nous.
Ils découvrent aussi beaucoup de choses.
Maria qui va au Taï chi tous les
jeudis matin, qui a de fortes douleurs,
grâce à ce Taï chi,
va se sentir différente.
Et pourtant, une agricultrice
de 95 ans qui aurait dit :
« Ben moi, le Taï chi ?
Non, pas du tout. »
Ou Marie-Thérèse qui dit : « Je n’ai pas
le temps de mourir ici à Kersalic,
parce qu’il va falloir que j’invite
plein de monde à la brasserie. »
Ou encore Jacqueline qui dit à son fils :
« La prochaine fois, tu téléphoneras
avant que tu viennes,
parce que je ne suis plus
à ta disposition quand même. »
Oui, ils sont devenus citoyens,
ils ont repris leur place dans la société
malgré tous les troubles
qu’ils peuvent avoir.
Aujourd’hui, j’ai la chance d’être la
maire d’une commune où il fait bon vivre,
avec une telle fierté par rapport
à une équipe qui a réussi à me suivre,
qui a réussi à changer son regard.
Mais j'ai besoin de vous pour ça aussi.
J’aimerais cet après-midi
que vous soyez nos ambassadeurs
du changement du regard
sur ces vieux d’aujourd’hui,
mais sans oublier que ces vieux-là,
ce sera nous demain.
Merci à vous.
(Applaudissements)